Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah. Let's begin.
Okay. So we are picking up with the conclusion of a Batman ghosts.
No worries. Right? This is the end of the Batman ghost stories story.
And I am a little bit on the fence about how this ends,
but I'm also excited at the same time, but overall,
the story was absolutely amazing, right?
And this is one of those stories that one I urge you guys buy. And two,
I'm going to, I'm going to buy the physical copy of it. But as you get,
most of you guys know, I only ever buy physical copies of comics.
If they're important to me at this point in my life,
after having spent so many years buying physical comics,
I just got rid of my collection. That is by digitally now, right?
It's just so much easier than walking around with like, you know,
20 comics at a time trying to read them. So, uh,
so the first thing we do here is we basically pick up with what is in essence,
the final flashback of the ghost stories story, right?
In the sense that we have Batman and we have, or really Bruce Wayne,
and we have a ghost maker kind of having this conversation.
And the interesting thing about this is that Bruce Wayne kind of sees us
training as being completed, right? He's basically done. And at this point,
he's ready to head back to Gotham city and become a crime fighter.
And when he's met by ghost maker,
the responsive ghost maker is you're not ready. And when he asks,
why there's this really amazing conversation that goes on between the two now
for ghost maker, as a character,
it's very easy to talk him up where it could have been very easy to talk him up
as your stereotypical villain, right? A guy who just does stuff.
And he's essentially a vigilante and he's got no regard for human life and
nothing matters or anything like that.
But the reality is that while he does have a disregard for human life,
his motivation for it is actually altruistic.
And I know that sounds like an oxymoron.
How could you believe in doing the right thing? Because it's the right thing.
And at the same time, not care about people, right?
But one of the things to understand is that doing the right thing does not
necessarily mean the preservation of life.
Those two things are not mutually exclusive that in a world of like
utilitarianism, for example, doing the best,
or at least the needs of the many outweigh the needs of the fear,
which could mean sacrificing a few people. And that's kind of the stance of,
of ghosts maker, really. And to kind of put a finer point on it.
That's this whole perception. When he has this conversation with Batman,
he beats it. He says like, you're not ready here.
And when Batman asks why he says, because the entire motivation that you,
that you exist on exists in two fronts,
the first is that you're going back to Gotham city to fight crime because your
mommy and your daddy got shot and your that's your entire motivation,
your motivation is external, right?
You're like a person that wants to lose weight to impress a girl, right.
As soon as he has that girl impressed,
what's his motivation to keep losing weight anymore. At that point,
like his entire motivation has gone and he'll slip right back to where he was
before. When you get to a point where you believe that, like, you're,
you finally avenge the idea of your mom and your dad,
then where does Gotham city go from there? Do you retire?
Let it fall back into the hands of those individuals who corrupted in the first
place. What's how does that, how does that whole end result?
The other part of that is in order for you to succeed,
you need an internal motivation. And that's where,
where you kind of outlined the difference between himself and Bruce Wayne,
that with Bruce Wayne, he wants to get basically it's its vengeance.
It's the most basic principle is vengeance because as mom and dad were gone,
mom and dad got shot and he's going to get back to crime, right?
He's not going to get back at an individual person,
but he's going to get practice at the entire principle of crime for ghosts
maker. It's legitimately wanting to make the world better.
It's truthfully wanting to actually make the world a better place.
It's it's really just altruism at its finest.
Now where the two of them disagree is the collateral damage. That when,
when ghost maker looks at Batman, he says,
the problem that you have here is that you basically let every small little
thing get to you. You know, in this instance, your mom and dad were shot.
Now you want to get back at crunch.
But the entire motivation is that nobody will ever feel the same thing you felt.
Well, what happens if they do?
What happens if you get to a crime scene a minute to a minute later than it
actually happened?
What happens if you can't stop that guy from pulling the trigger and an innocent
person dies? What happens? Well,
then now you see yourself as a failure because you didn't live up to your
motivation, right?
You didn't live up to the cause that you were supposed to be pushing on at the
same time, you're basically selfish, right?
Like I want to basically make the world a better place. We talked about that.
You're just a really upset kid who wants to go back and make Gotham a better
place. But the reality is making the world better,
means not caring about people. And again,
I know it sounds weird to here's how we explained it, right?
It's actually a genius way. It's, it's a really interesting way of doing it.
His whole stance is if you don't really care about people,
then the ends justify the means.
And if the end result is basically what amounts,
so more or less a utopian world, where there really is no crime,
because you're finding the concept on crime of crime, on multiple levels, right.
You're finding it on the street level by putting away criminals.
And then you're finding it on the various other levels in terms of why people
commit crimes, you're basically stemming it, right? So like, you know,
economic inequality, different things like that.
You're fighting it all on multiple fronts. You know,
the idea of creating a utopian style world outweighs the number of people who
died. And that's true. That is a true statement.
If the end result is that the world wouldn't inherently become a utopian place,
not by way of like some kind of fascism or anything like that.
But by people being able to just kind of live their lives in peace,
not having to worry about crime, pursuing the things they love the most, right.
Just kind of enjoying their lives essentially.
Then it's worth the sacrifices of all those individuals who were killed. Now.
It doesn't mean that ghost maker's going to go through and just murder innocent
people. But it does mean that he has to kind of regard people, right?
He has to look at two circumstances and say, okay,
I could stop this guy here from killing that one person.
Or I could let them kill that one person,
follow them back to their base of operations, which I don't know.
And men get all the criminals at the same time.
So I will sacrifice that one guy in order to apprehend those bigger guys. Right.
And it kind of sucks, but it's one of these things where,
when it comes to the world of fighting crime and trying to do better in the
world, you can't have it all. You can't have your cake and eat it too.
You can't spare the life of the innocent guy and get all the criminals at the
same time. More often than not. It doesn't work that way.
It'd be nice if it did.
But the reality of the world we live in is you have to make choices.
And sometimes these choices will be ones you don't want to make.
But at the end of the day,
what you're getting out of the choice you make is better than what you're losing
in the choice that you're making. Right? So it's, it's one of these interesting,
interesting kind of philosophies, interesting situations,
but that's where him and Bruce Wayne differ because Bruce Wayne believes that he
can have it all right.
He can save the innocent guy and he can top of the criminal and he can kind of
make it, make the day better and, and make it Gotham city a much safer place.
The irony of all this is that if you look at the history of Wayne,
he's basically a dog chasing his tail. The criminals never really get fixed.
They never really get changed. They are, they're always bad guys, right?
He really hasn't made any headway in making Gotham better. If anything,
he's made Gotham worse. And so that's kind of the irony here.
That's kind of the, the,
the whole point that ghost maker was trying to teach him is you're not ready to
actually do what needs to be done because you believe that you need to save
everybody when all the,
while the reality is some folks you're just going to have to let die in order to
catch the bigger fish. It sucks. It's not there,
but nobody ever said the world was as well, because that, you know,
ultimately you kind of have Bruce Wayne and ghost maker just disagreeing and
going their separate ways. Right? And so far as, uh, Bruce Wayne basically says,
fine, I'm going back to Gotham city. I don't ever want to see you there.
And that's when the truce gets struck where ghost maker says, okay, fine.
Didn't, that's the rule. Any city that I'm currently in,
you did not come to you. Right? If a city has been seen by me, right.
In the sense that like I've been there, I've involved myself there,
then you never come there.
And I will never go to any city that you've touched foot in.
These are our own little territories,
our own little places where wherever we set up shop, nobody else gets involved.
And so what we ended up doing is switching up to the, really the,
the end of the last video, when count Hunter intends to kill Harley Quinn.
And that's kind of the funny thing here, right?
That you have this discussion between these two guys are really just kind of
between Batman and Carmen Hunter,
where Batman tries to talk him down the entire time this was going on,
ghost maker is watching all this unfold. And, and, and really the,
the point that ghost maker was trying to prove to Batman is if you put people in
a circumstance where there's no reward for doing the right thing,
but no consequence for doing the wrong thing,
people will do the wrong thing because more often than not,
the wrong thing is easier. The lazy user model and the least effort principle,
right,
at least ever principle was a concept created by George Ziff back in 1949,
which basically said that like, people want the want,
the greatest reward for the least amount of work. The laser user,
the lazy user model kind of builds on that work. Now,
the idea of Elise ever principle expands way beyond more than simply just,
you know, work and reward and stuff like that.
It actually encompasses every facet of human and really just every ecosystem in
the world, right? Animal life, plant life, even electricity, things like that,
the path of least resistance.
But it's kind of like that grocery cart litmus test.
I don't know if you guys ever heard of that,
but the grocery cart litmus test is this concept in social psychology,
where basically it kind of answers the question.
What would people do in a situation where again,
there's no reward for doing the right thing,
but no consequence for doing the wrong thing.
And so if you have a grocery card and you take it out, you know,
you bring it out to the parking lot. You put all your groceries in your car.
There's no consequence nobody's going to arrest you or give you a ticket.
Nothing bad is going to happen.
If you just leave that grocery cart sitting next to your vehicle,
and then you pull out, drive home and that's it. But you know,
it's the right thing to do to put the grocery cart back in the carousel. Again,
it's a minuscule thing,
but ultimately it's designed to kind of test people and put them in a situation
where, you know, where you ask the question, what will they do in this?
What will they do in this situation?
A lot of people leave the grocery cart sitting next to their cart,
which is basically kind of a test of whether or not people can actually
self-govern right. Well, people do the right thing,
even if there's no reward for doing the right thing.
And the answer to that is more often than not.
No people usually want that's the whole point that ghost maker is creating here
for Batman to see that clown Hunter has been given the ability to kill Harley
Quinn. He can take all his anger and all his, all his revenge,
all his wrath out on Harley Quinn,
because she was there when his parents were killed at the hands of the joker.
She's not the joker himself, but she's the closest the clown Hunter can get.
And so in this moment, when calm Hunter's being talked to by Batman and clown,
Hunter has the choice to either walk away or to kill Harley Quinn.
He goes in for the kill and had Batman not breaking himself out of his bow,
out of his bonds, thrown his batarang at Harley Quinn, which she can in turn,
cut herself out and then free yourself before, before calm Hunter killer.
And before bat, you know, if that man had not been able to subdue count, Hunter,
Holly Quinn would have been killed. He would have been to his base or instinct.
And the whole idea behind this here,
this is what's intriguing is the whole idea behind this is that while,
while count,
Hunter's kind of the minority here in so far that Carly Quinn's turned over a
new leaf. Batman never really had a new leaf to turn over in the first place,
but he's always taken the high road.
I would surmise these two are the exception to the rule and not the rule itself.
And the reason why is simple Harley Quinn, it creates this case for us,
where she basically starts talking to them and saying, Hey, look,
I was a psychiatrist. Let me talk to you for a second. Right.
And almost talks to them like a patient. She says, look,
there's something you need to understand. Right. Hear me out.
And then when I'm done talking, you can kill me if you really want to.
And so he's like, okay, fine.
And one of the things she basically says here is I'm not really responsible for
the things that I did, and it's not really set in so many words,
but it's basically, I was at a point in my life where I was at a really, really,
really low place. Right. I was in a really bad spot.
And then suddenly a man came along who told me everything that I wanted to hear
that made me feel special.
That made me feel relevant in a world where I felt painfully irrelevant and I
got carried away with it.
But the crazy thing about this is one thing to understand with Harley Quinn,
she wasn't hypnotized. She wasn't tricked, she wasn't mind controlled.
She was manipulated to a degree, but at the same time,
she also understood the consequences of her actions.
She knew that she was doing the wrong thing.
We know that she knows she was doing the wrong thing because over the course of
her publication history,
she recognized the problems she had and actually tried to leave the joker,
but kept going back. But if she understands the problem,
but then makes temporary efforts to fix the problem,
but then ultimately relapses.
Then that means she is responsible for her actions because she understands that
what she's doing is wrong. And so because of that, the, the,
the kind of argument of, well, I'm not really responsible for what I did on me.
I'm sorry that your, your parents died,
but it's not really my fault at the end of the day. It still is.
And she understands that when she goes, as far as to say,
like I made a lot of mistakes, I did a lot of things that I shouldn't have done,
and I'm going to pay those consequences for the rest of my life.
But I'm just trying to be a better version of myself. Right. And you know, when,
when she sits down and offers a kind of apology to Kevin, you know,
that's really all he gets out of her in reality.
That's all he really can get out of her.
And initially it doesn't seem to be enough. And he actually intended, you know,
it looks like he intends to go in for the kill, but then essentially does it,
right. He actually does. Doesn't really kill Harley Quinn.
And so that moment of an apology seems to be enough for him to kind of say,
okay, I need to be on my own and rethink things. Now,
the reality of this is that if this was in the real world,
Holly Quinn would have died because if we had a situation where somebody had
killed your parents in a violent crime,
and then in turn showed up to you and said, Hey, I'm sorry,
I killed your parents at some future point in time. That wouldn't be enough.
Right? I mean an apology. It's all you get. That wouldn't be enough, right?
I mean, we'd, we'd be screening for blood right. Eye for an eye, you know?
And so he, you know, any normal and would've stabbed her to death.
And that's why I think the philosophy of ghosts maker, it rings true.
It really does ring true here because we're, we're con hunters. Okay, fine.
You know, or, you know, I got to get where you're coming from. Again,
it's all the exception to the rule that under any normal circumstance,
they would have lashed out. They would have attacked them.
And so for the most part,
the Batman comics in terms of how they're being shown here are very optimistic,
which is kind of ironic given how pessimistic the city of Gotham is.
And that's one of the reasons why ghosts maker being involved here makes things
so intriguing. Her stance on this is I could catch that voice if I wanted to.
And then he goes so far as to ask Batman,
what were you trying to prove there by, by having this,
by convincing this kid or getting this kid to listen to Harley Quinn and then
walk away from the idea of killing her,
what do you believe that you've proved here? And the stance of Batman is, um,
it's not about proving anything, right?
Like I just genuinely care about the kid and I didn't want to see him ruin his
life.
But the other thing that you kind of have to ask here is that if you look at
somebody like ghosts maker, and you say, okay,
this is a guy who approached the world with the idea that the world could
legitimately be saved and killed.
Criminals is a small price to pay for the betterment of the billions of people
across the face of the world. Then in turn, the question has to be asked,
how did he get to that point? And how does he maintain that position?
Is you really just that obstinate, right?
As he really just that unwilling to listen the reason,
or if he's really as intelligent as Bruce Wayne believes he is,
and is really as intelligent as we're being told, he is,
then he has to have come across different situations over the course of his
life.
That reaffirmed the idea that a villains are given a choice between reforming or
staying villains they'll stay villains, right?
Because it's either what they're used to. It's easier,
but people will be able to be more likely to commit a crime,
to achieve a goal than they will be to. We work hard, right? Again,
the least effort principle that people want the greatest reward for them,
the least amount of work that they can do. And so, because of that,
like a fight kind of breaks out between the two of them, you know, kind of this,
this final fight that we get. And that then goes as far as to say it, like,
do you know how many times I could have killed Harley Quinn over the years?
Right?
How many easy it would have been to just eliminate Joker's closest associates,
but then nobody learns. Nobody changes. Nothing's better in the end.
Now the response of ghost maker is not everyone can be safe and the response of
Batman is, but most people can.
And you usually cannot tell when you're face-to-face with them on the worst day
of their life. But here's the irony about all that, right?
This is why I advocate for the joker being killed by Batman in college,
obviously come back at some point online, but it's why I think Kelly,
the joker in Gotham is the only right thing,
because this assumes that the person you're facing off against is a person of
reasonable, rational sound,
mind who is otherwise taken into a situation that they normally wouldn't put
themselves in, right? Like a husband loses his job.
And in order to make ends meet, he robs a bank to buy food.
That's a very tangible and realistic scenario that we see unfolded even now
out there in the world. Now, if Batman would have come across that guy,
while he's robbing that bank in that moment of desperation,
then Batman's statement rings true. Like you cannot really,
you can't see people how great they can be when you're seeing them in the worst
day of their life. Right. That moment of desperation.
But the thing about the joker is he's always been crazy. The Joker's not a guy.
Well, I guess ever since he became the joker,
but the is not a guy where he gets up in the morning, he gets a cup of coffee.
He watches the morning news and he says, okay, time to go be crazy.
And then he just goes and does crazy stuff. The Joker's crazy, 24 hours a day,
he sleeps crazy, right? He eats crazy. You know, he like,
he is constantly crazy. He is beyond being helped any possible help.
Any reformation, any fixing him is a pipe dream.
This idea of Batman saying like the average person can be fixed.
They can be saved.
That's true because Holly Quinn was not nearly as crazy as the joker.
She wasn't nearly as lost as the Joe for what,
there was always that portion of her that knew that she was doing the wrong
thing.
And Batman could tap into that and always try to find a way to bring her back.
Even if she wasn't readily accepting of it, where the joker that's gone,
any semblance of humanity that joker previously had any semblance of rationality
outside of whatever it is is it I can do to get that man to chase me is the
thing that I will do. That's gone. The joker is, is, is really like,
he's not really even human anymore. Right? And so, because of that,
there's no saving him.
There's no point where Batman will ever come across a situation and say, okay,
now I've quote unquote, fixed the joker. He's back to being a rational person.
Everything will be safe. I guess the white Knight might work.
And so far it's like feeding him joker pills, right?
But in terms of organically getting him back back to being normal,
that's never going to happen. And so, as long as the joker is alive,
the joker will do everything. He can to get Batman, to chase him.
And because of his psych, uh, his, his, his psychosis, and because of his, uh,
his being associate path,
he has a complete and total disregard for the thoughts, feelings, emotions,
and lives of other people, right. They're irrelevant to him.
They're pawns in this game that he plays with Batman.
And so the only way to save people from the joker is to kill the joker.
The fact that that man never done that yet really says volumes about Batman
stance on sacrificing innocent people on behalf of keeping the joker alive,
right? It is a reverse version of utilitarianism, but done in a perverse way.
And that's, that's something that I want to clear.
That's why I advocate for the joker being killed in light of all that.
I don't really see how any rational person could advocate for the joker.
Staying alive as a Batman should kill him. Right? At this point,
it's just the right thing to do.
And so it's one of these things where Batman kind of gives up the fight with
ghost maker says, look, we've been fighting long enough, right?
We've been fighting and fighting and fighting and fighting. And in all reality,
I've got my place here. You've got your place there,
wherever it is that you happen to be, I'm tired of fighting you.
I'm tired of doing this.
And so in response like Batman starts to put his guard back on and ghost maker
kind of says, you know,
I always kind of wished you'd come charging out into with one of your cars.
Right. I was always jealous of your cars. I always thought they were cool.
You know, and that means like I'm building a new one and he's like,
is it a flying car? It's like, Nope, it's just a wheels on the ground car.
Right? Because remember joker Batman's lost pretty much all his wealth, right.
He's not really as wealthy as he used to be. Ah, he,
all that money has been seized, right? I mean, well,
I guess really Lucius Fox is the one that runs Wayne enterprises,
but Bruce Wayne himself is no longer in his company. Right.
That was one of the big fallout, fallout aspects of joker war.
It really is just him and his wits and, you know,
using whatever the resources you can to do whatever it is that he can,
but ultimately ghost makers like, okay, fine.
Then I'll be watching you on the go snack. Right.
I'll be keeping an eye on you in your city because I'm curious to see,
are you really going to be able to STEM the flow of crime here in Gotham?
Or are you going to be like, you've always been a dog chasing his tail,
wondering why things aren't getting better, but then Batman stops him and says,
you don't actually have to leave here. Right? Like, I mean,
this truth that we have is there because we really have more respect for each
other. And it's more of a rivalry than ultra outright hatred for each other.
But at the end of the day, we both respect the other's ability. Right?
You bring a level of skill to Gotham that nobody else in the bat family has.
And between you and me, we compliment each other exceedingly well, so come June,
come to Gotham city, but come and help me save this city. Right?
If you believe that I could do things better than show me how to do things
better. Right. Don't kill anybody in my city, but let's make things better.
We can fight crime on a multitude of different levels. Right.
We can do it in a myriad of different ways.
And so initially the response of ghost maker is, man, I don't,
I don't really know about that. That man is like, come on, dude. Like,
what do you have to lose?
And so ultimately ghost maker accepts ghost maker accepts and joins Batman in
Gotham city and becomes part of the bath family.
Now here's the thing I'm kind of, I'm, I'm, I'm excited about this, right?
I'm a little iffy on how it ends because of the fact that like,
we're not going to find out until March, which kind of me off.
But I do like the idea of ghost maker. I love the character of ghost maker.
He's amazing, absolutely adore the character of ghost maker. Um,
I think it's one of the most interesting additions to the bad family that's been
done in recent years.
And when I say recent years since like grant Morrison's run, right?
Like since Batman incorporated, I think it's cool.
And maybe even before Batman incorporated,
I think ghost maker is probably one of the most interesting characters ever
introduced to the Batman mythos. I'm really excited to see where it goes.
But the reason why we have to wait until March is because next month we get
future state. So yes, we are getting the future state event and DC comics with,
uh, the future bat wing, the son of Lucius Fox. I'm excited about this.
What I'm excited about,
about the new Batman coming and the new new future state Batman comics.
But with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end. Uh,
if you guys are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the rod court, if you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a like,
and I wouldn't know what you guys think about this story. Right?
Leave a comment down in the description and, uh,
or in the comment section rather, and I will catch you all later.
Please.